[Music]
welcome back at the start of the
pandemic fauci and other experts told us
that
60 of america would have to be
vaccinated before we could get back to
normal
then it became 70 then 80 percent now
fouchy tells the new york times it could
be
90 and he admitted he'd been
deliberately moving the goal post
because america wasn't ready to hear the
truth
but whether it's 60 70 80 or 90 it is
all part
of the establishment's vaccine
groupthink and it is
dangerously wrong if we just targeted
the vulnerable
we could end lockdowns by the end of
this month instead
fauci and the establishment want to keep
it going
despite all the death and destruction
they're causing
sarah it's just unbelievable to me they
they
remember at the beginning when those of
us who are arguing against the lockdown
said no there's
an alternative strategy here protect the
vulnerable and then they would say to
you well how are you going to protect
the vulnerable
what does that mean even mean now we
have a highly specific way of doing it
i.e the vaccines and they don't even
interested
they don't care about whether this is
scientifically justified it seems to me
they just want to keep this lockdown
going
because they're ideologically committed
to it
that's absolutely right stephen just
even look at the beginning of this year
with dr fauci and the masks
obviously he thinks it's okay to just
say whatever comes out of his mouth
whether it's the truth or not truth or
not to the american people remember in
the beginning
he was saying no no please don't go out
and buy masks it's really not going to
help you that much at all
it's not going to help anyone make sure
they're out there for the medical
professionals and then he said well i
didn't mean to say that
i was just trying to save the masks for
the medical professionals and now he's
moving the goalposts
all the way to 95 and look at what's
happening in great britain look at
what's happening in canada
look at the man the gentleman that went
out and you know hugged people
in the street in front of the police and
then they handcuffed him
because they said he was exposing people
and putting people's lives in danger
this is a trampling of our rights our
human rights
and how far will this go and i think
what you said is absolutely something
that we all need to think about
how far are we willing to allow this to
happen
before we actually start questioning and
saying wait a minute when is enough
enough
and when are we going to get the truth
from our medical professionals
exactly and janelle you know when when
the lockdown started the
the justification was look we know from
the data
that most people who get this are going
to be fine
have mild or zero symptoms but obviously
as we know
it's incredibly dangerous for a small
proportion and they their and their data
is very clear that's elderly people
so even though you may not be at risk we
are worried about you
taking it home to grandma and infecting
her if we can vaccinate grandma and
grandpa and the people who are at risk
then the justification for the lockdown
just falls away
but there's no acceptance of that
that's right that's completely right um
you know it's almost like they want to
completely destroy this economy until we
have nothing left
and it's a really scary thought and you
know i think the biggest issue for me is
that we have someone that's in
government who feels like they can make
decisions for my healthcare much better
than i can for myself
and you know had you told us the truth
and let us decide what's best
then we probably would be in a different
position but instead
he decided that it's better to lie to
the american people
and and be untruthful versus allowing us
to make these decisions
and and to your point you know the
economy is what is taking the hit they
are taking the hit these small
businesses
these restaurants you know we talked to
a restaurant owner just this past
weekend
who had to shut down one of his
restaurants that he said he'll probably
never
reopen and then he lost half of his
staff and so the level of stress that's
causing
um our business owners and the economy
and just everyone that's a part of this
is just
unbelievable and it's sad that you know
we're not
that that fouchy is not getting the same
level of criticism
that they gave the president when he
simply wanted to make sure he made a
strong decision without jumping to
conclusions
and that the other aspect of the vaccine
thing i'm just noticing is how the rest
of the media
are just desperate to try and find any
way to criticize
president trump even though it was his
action that got us the vaccine so
quickly they're saying that the rollout
is a disaster and so let's just put up
the data on this which shows the
proportion of populations of certain
countries large countries
that have already been vaccinated this
is a league table that the us is
practically at the top
of the only major country doing better
than us right now in terms of
vaccinations is the uk
they approved the vaccine of course days
before we did
we're rapidly catching up seems to me
they're just literally not prepared to
give the president credit for anything
and they just want to hit him
every way they can even when the facts
don't justify it
well you'll remember steve it was
actually dr fauci who said that it would
be 18 months at a minimum
before we would even have a vaccine but
as a consequence
of the president's focus and marshaling
our nation's great resources we were
able to have that time so
it turns out dr fauci is a government
official
he is not yoda he is not the oracle of
all things
true or false but you're right that the
medical industrial complex right now
is at a zenith of power these unelected
people quite literally have the power to
deem our fellow americans
essential or non-essential and they can
rack and stack different populations of
americans for prioritizing the vaccine
distribution
i found an interesting website
covetedpredictor.com
where some american innovators found a
way to use your dna
sequences alongside other comorbidities
and predictors to
ascertain what your risk score would be
for covet
using science would be a lot better than
using
politics or just the desire of
government officials to exercise their
control over people
when making these decisions that are so
consequential to our lives
well i mean that's so right all of you
made such great points and we're going
to keep fighting this and unfortunately
it sounds like we're going to have to
keep fighting it
for a long time to come because of the
lunacy
of the establishment exactly as you said
matt alright thank you all very much